[Music]
mariah carey is giving ryan reynolds
major side eye when it comes to his
rendition of mariah's 1995 hit fantasy
[Music]
mariah's post comes days after the free
guy actor shared his version of the
track on tick tock the grammy winner
decided to duet the video and naturally
she slayed but were loving the shady
side eye
she even jokes in the caption that
wasn't part of the plan
[Music]
ryan's tick tock video also comes after
his decision to include the song in his
new action comedy movie free guy where
his character has a run-in with his own
fantasy
[Music]
don't have a good day have a great day
that's it
and earlier this month e.t chatted with
the actor who explained how the song
landed in the movie you know i remember
one of the earliest contributions i made
to the script you know we all did uh
drafts of the script we all did me sean
and zach pam we all did rewrites the
script was mariah carey's fantasy i put
that in the script and it was like it
really became like an engine for the
movie and i love that he also gushed
over how mariah's music is a staple in
his and wife blake lively's house were
you jamming to some fantasy by mc at
home with blake the gals oh yeah man we
were you know we're we're obsessives we
love we love mariah we love you know we
love music we love celebration i mean
that's that's what music is it's so it
just drives you into a feeling would you
consider yourself a lambly uh yo yeah
for sure in a sea of wolves
i am definitely one watch out
but this friendship between ryan and
mariah runs deeper than music check out
this pic of them together joined by
blake and mariah's twins daughter monroe
and son moroccan who is rocking a
deadpool mask ryan even commented on the
pic
whoa my vision board became a photo i'm
very lucky to have that
[Music]